Hi ihr Lieben!
Heute geht's total gesund bei mir zu!
Ihr wisst ja, dass ich mir überlegt habe ich zeige euch zwischendurch immer wieder sehr, sehr proteinreiche Rezepte.
Die sind besonders gut geeignet, wenn ihr z.B. abnehmen möchtet oder wenn ihr einfach
eine gesunde Ernährung an den Tag legen möchtet.
Wir haben jetzt auch überlegt im Januar doch so ein bisschen mehr auf Eiweiß zu setzen.
Und ich mach jetzt heute ne richtig leckere Bowl.
Und zwar ist eine Bowl einfach ein Gemisch aus etwas Kohle-halte...äh Kohlehydrate-haltigem -
kleiner Zungenbrecher - und gaanz viel Gemüse und einem Dressing.
Und das ist sogar vegan abwandelbar! Nur mal zur Info, falls ihr vegan seid.
Und meine Basis ist heute Quinoa. Ihr könntet statt Quinoa auch Bulgur nehmen, also Weizen oder Reis,
also da könnt ihr euch einfach das nehmen, was ihr grade da habt oder das, was ihr am liebsten mögt.
Bei mir ist es heute wie gesagt Quinoa.
Den werd ich jetzt nach Packungsanleitung garen, also in Salzwasser.
Und dann sehen wir uns nach dem Garvorgang wieder.
Unser Quinoa ist jetzt fertig gegart und ich möcht ihn jetzt nicht so heiß in die Bowl geben
und wir haben auch noch so ein bisschen was vorzubereiten,
daher nehm ich ihn jetzt aus dem Topf und geb ihm zum Abkühlen in eine große Schüssel.
Und danach machen wir mit den Kichererbsen weiter.
Ich nehm immer ganz gerne Kichererbsen aus der Dose,
dann spart man sich diese Einweichzeit und die sind dann eben schon weich.
Und ihr könnt jetzt hier einfach würzen nach Herzenslust.
Ich persönlich mag ganz gerne Paprikapulver, natürlich Salz.
Was bei mir nie fehlen darf ist Zwiebelgranulat, das mag ich auch ganz gerne.
Und unbedingt auch noch ein bisschen Kreuzkümmel dazugeben!
Denn ansonsten blähen ja Kichererbsen so ein bisschen auf und das wirkt dann eben entgegen.
So, einmal alles schön verrühren und den Ofen hab ich übrigens vorgeheizt auf 220 Grad Ober- und Unterhitze
und das kommt jetzt ungefähr 23,25,26 Minuten rein.
Da müsst ihr einfach ein Auge drauf haben und gerne auch immer mal wieder ein bisschen wenden.
So und jetzt rösten die Kichererbsen ja grad vor sich hin im Ofen und ich hab mir gedacht ich nutz die Zeit,
um euch jetzt mal meinen Tofu zu zeigen. Wir haben übrigens das erste Mal ne Bowl
bei Dean&David gegessen. Wie kam das?
Ihr habt gesagt: "Kiki, mach doch mal - das war ein Dressing wolltet ihr -
mach doch mal das Dressing von Dean&David nach!"
Und Hamza und ich fahren da hin und dann haben wir direkt nur die Bowl gesehen und dachten:
"Hey, wir gönnen und jetzt mal so ne leckere Bowl!"
Und die war mega lecker, die war auch mit Tofu.
Und wie fandest du's?
(H: Ich war danach 2 Tage lang satt!)
Hamza war danach 2 Tage lang satt!
Tofu ist nämlich auch so 'ne richtige Eiweißquelle! Das hier ist jetzt Räuchertofu
auf Kichererbsenbasis. Es gibt ja verschiedene Arten von Tofu
und es ist eben ein veganer Fleischersatz.
Was ich gemacht habe ist: ich hab das Ganze eine Stunde zuvor in Sojasoße, ganz normale Sojasoße eingelegt
damit es schön einzieht. Wenn ihr keine Zeit habt, dann reichen vielleicht auch nur 20, 30 Minuten.
Und jetzt bratet ihr das Ganze in etwas Öl in der beschichteten Pfanne an.
Den Tofu jetzt 4-5min lang schön anbraten von allen Seiten
und danach den Herd ganz, ganz dringend anschalten, denn wenn wir den Honig dazugeben,
darf er nicht stark erhitzt werden. Das ist ja bei Honig so.
Und wer jetzt vegan ist, der nimmt einfach Agavendicksaft.
Also den Honig jetzt nochmal schön schmelzen lassen und dann Paprikapulver dazugeben.
Ich geb gern ganz viel süßes Paprikapulver dazu und ein bisschen was scharfes.
Scharf mag ich nämlich nicht so gerne.
Und Salz braucht ihr in der Regel nicht, das ist ja schon salzig genug durch die Sojasoße.
Das geb ich jetzt einfach wieder zurück in meine Schale und dann zeig euch das Joghurt-Dressing.
Und dann haben wir alle Komponenten fertig und können die Bowl anrichten.
Für unser Dressing nehmt ihr jetzt ganz einfach Naturjoghurt oder ihr nehmt eine vegane Alternative,
da geht ja z.B. auch Sojajoghurt.
Und da gebt ihr jetzt eine gepresste Knoblauchzehe rein.
Außerdem Salz und Pfeffer und natürlich ein bisschen Honig für die Süße.
Und dem so ein bisschen entgegen zu wirken - das gibt nochmal so einen tollen Geschmack -
ein bisschen Limettensaft und wenn ihr keine Limette da habt, einfach Zitrone.
Und dann verrührt ihr das und fertig ist das Dressing und es schmeckt mega, mega gut.
Und jetzt haben wir ja alles vorbereitet, das heißt ihr nehmt euch jetzt eine Bowl -
also nichts anderes als eine Schüssel - und gebt da alles rein.
Auf den Untergrund der Bowl gebt ihr jetzt ganz einfach das Quinoa oder wenn ihr z.B. Bulgur oder Reis habt -
ich sag immer Bulgur, obwohl es ja kein deutsches Wort ist...naja!
Ihr wisst wie ich das mein!
(H: Jeder kennt's!
Jeder kennt's, ja. Selbst im deutschen Raum sagt man ja schon  Bulgur.
Und genau, wir beginnen jetzt damit und dann schichten wir einfach portionsweise.
In meine persönliche Bowl kommt jetzt natürlich frischer Rucola, Tomaten - da nehm ich gerne Cherrytomaten -
außerdem Radieschen, rote Zwiebeln und Möhren.
Natürlich unser Tofu, den wir grad vorbereitet haben, Avocado -
bei der Avocado mach ich's so, da teil ich ihn erstmal in 2,
oder sie in 2, besser gesagt und schneide sie in ganz, ganz dünne Scheiben.
Dann natürlich unser Joghurt-Dressing, die vorbereiteten Kichererbsen und nochmal
für etwas mehr Biss Cashewkerne und gerne zum Schluss noch ein bisschen Sesam.
Man kann sich natürlich auch immer wieder Joghurt-Dressing nachnehmen, nachreichen.
Weil bei der Bowl ist es generell so: man richtet zwar alles portionsweise an
aber am Ende wird sowieso alles miteinander verrührt und dann vermengt sich alles
und das schmeckt einfach wunderbar und sättigt vor allem.
Ihr könnt das Ganze jetzt natürlich nachmachen.
Und das ist nur eine Idee von tausenden.
Eine Bowl kann man total variieren.
Ich schreib euch meine ganz genauen Mengenangaben unten in die Videobeschreibung.
Wenn euch dieses Rezept gefallen hat und ihr gerne öfter mal gesunde Rezepte haben möchtet,
dann schreibt's mir in die Kommentare.
Hinterlasst mir auf jeden Fall ein Däumchen nach oben um mir zu zeigen,
ob euch das Rezept gefallen hat.
Und dann würde ich auch mal sagen: Gerne mehr Rezeptvorschläge!
Alles entsteht hier durch euch!
Ein Abo dalassen...das war jetzt aber viel, was ich von euch verlange, ne?
Naja, das dauert ja nicht lang!
Von daher wünsch ich euch jetzt noch einen wunderschönen Tag,
viel Freude beim Nachmachen und bis bald!
Tschüss!